das trifft mich so sehr leute herzlich
willkommen zu anderen bio es ist wieder
zeit für eine neue nach diesem video
hast du person xy video reihe waren die
quoten wird ein rotes teil so dass man
da wo du bist du natürlich ist wenn mir
gestern kann aber auf jeden fall leute
ich habe vor einigen tagen einigen
wochen schon mal so ein video gemacht
nach diesem video hast du jackpot das
ist gemischt angekommen das video hat
auf 8006 1000 displays bekommen was echt
richtig vieles für einen kanal und das
liegt glaube ich daran dass einige das
nicht so ganz verstanden da musst du
persönlich genommen haben deswegen ihre
vorderleute es ist natürlich wir schauen
uns einfach diese videos an und
reagieren darauf und gucken was die
menschen dazu machen erstmal vorweg für
die palette die nicht wissen wir keine
jenner ist keine generation
amerikanische reality tv darstellerin
ist aber bekannt geworden hat so eine
eigene kosmetiklinie mittlerweile und
ihr zeit könnte man auch okay das storm
ii heißt ist der erste band das sie
angeblich unfreundlich ist nochmal der
sinn des videos ist dass man dann nach
kalidünger hast das ist das ziel des
videos aber ganz ehrlich ich bin bei
solchen videos auch fährt wie soll man
auf so etwas reagieren also erstmal auch
geht es mit den kindern ist schon ein
bisschen so
die fans sind heute froh die zu sehen
berühren die und dann so don't touch me
kate winslet ist schon recht krass das
kann man auch anders sagen aber was soll
jetzt vor diesem typen los so geht auf
sie zu ob der straße und fragt die auf
du das heißt auf deutsch übersetzt
ungefähr was hast du mit der mond so
alles drauf eine fremde person einfach
auf der straße menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend
das thema
[Applaus]
okay das war schon bald erscheint darum
dass die andere
das ist glaube ich kenne sich im kleid
von kay wollten keine partout nicht
bereit war diese zeit abzugeben kenne
ich leider eins zu eins hoffen meinem
bruder also wie gesagt heute man muss
dabei auch verbleiben finde ich jetzt an
der stelle nicht so krass aber ich kann
mal kurz eine sache zwischen reingeben
informiere ich bin persönlich nicht so
ein großer kelly john cena ich gesagt
ich ganz ehrlich sagen weil gleich dazu
ja ich glaube dass keine gender so ein
bisschen den eindruck vermittelt dass es
im mega cool ist sich so krasse arrogant
darzustellen also kurz gesagt mag ich
einfach nicht so diese diese einstellung
die die rüber bringt und wie das dann
auch heute wird junge mädchen denken ist
ja natürlich sogar auch kylie ist mein
vorbild jetzt tue ja auch so als wenn
ich die größte princess und die war okay
okay okay okay das ist halt auch so eine
sache leute man muss mit berücksichtigen
wenn man über eine person redet wie
keller die für viele leute ein großes
vorbild ist dass sie einen sehr großen
einfluss auf diese menschen hat und wenn
man großen einfluss so leute hat muss
man auch immer darüber nachdenken wie
man sich verhält um mit diesem einfluss
richtig umzugehen und dem fall von kylie
jenner heißt das welches schönheitsideal
übermittelt quasi wollten klar jeder
kann seinen eigenen körper machen was er
will aber welches shirt schicke ich raus
in die welt und was denkt sich ein
zwölfjähriges mädchen aus den usa und
ein 14-jähriges aus deutschland was
denken die sich was ein schönes bild von
der frau ist soll das problem dabei ist
er dann dass jedes sagen okay die ist
schön ich will auch so sein wie die aber
sie
die quasi das vorbild ist gibt überhaupt
nicht so dass sie krass übelsten sum
operiert ist und dass man quasi diesen
körper gar nicht erreichen kann ohne an
sich selbst herum zu schnippeln noch
über diese beiden bilder vergleicht so
wahrscheinlich war da keiner brust op
oder nicht dass ich irgendwelche ahnung
vom größten hätte aber okay wenn das
thema ok jetzt ob der punkt dass sie
weiter thema schlechtes vorbild
scheinbar hatte sie sich operieren
lassen hat dann so getan als hätte ich
es nicht gemacht und alle mädels zu
hause denken aber das ist die so schön
beten die an weil natürlich gibt sie das
nicht zu weil wenn sie zugibt dass sie
quasi operiert ist ein so vielen
verschiedenen stellen denken menschen zu
hause nicht mehr und das ist irgendwie
ein besserer mensch der etwas besseres
als ich und die menschen schauen in der
regel dann jemand anderem auch wenn die
sagen auf jede etwas besseres ja zum
beispiel nur eine person hat ultras aus
und du weißt untätig so auf die welt
gekommen ist einfach natürlich dann
siehst du verkehr zu der auch und kauft
ihre produkte und was ich war es als
wenn die gleiche person sie ist nicht
genauso attraktiv aber du weißt die hat
sich zwanzig mal operieren lassen und da
ist ein gar nicht so besonders an der
sondern jetzt einfach hunderttausend
euro in brüste lippen was weiß ich was
investiert der wird übrigens zeit dass
ich mal meine hände immer auf meine dass
die wissenschaft nicht anerkannte labels
gala ich muss wirklich sagen ich bin ich
würde nicht versucht er zu bleiben dabei
aber ich war nicht kommen und sagen ich
war mal von schon hier so aber diese
sache mit jungen menschen weltweit
irgendwas vorleben dass irgendwas
natürlich ist was absolut nicht
natürlich ist weil es einfach krassesten
suggeriert ist richard durchaus und
erreicht diese hält stufe dich jetzt
hoffen wir auf der gleichen skala
vermerkt habe ja und das thema mit der
lift weil leute gedacht die person ist
so attraktiv ich will auch so sein und
dann ist diese scheiße
gibt ja das passiert und menschen mit
einem glas angesagten lippen in den
rasenmäher reingelaufen was ich
[Applaus]
natürlich sieht für sie ihn verlässt
wien schicken natürlich ist auch
schwierig zwischen dem vater und dem
mädchen zu unterscheiden so der nächste
punkt ist dass sie ein verwöhntes belag
ist okay okay ich bin wirklich träger
leute das schlimmste an dem clip der den
ball nicht dass die person nicht weiß
man die eigene wäsche masse bekannt
seien bei der eltern ist immer gemacht
die ich nicht wirklich dazu gekommen
meyer wegen aber diese art und weise zu
reden
das für mich so sehr so redet doch kein
normaler menschlicher geistige
behinderung wenn ich diesen menschen zu
hören ist bei mir auf jeden fall weit
oben auf der offiziell gar nicht einhält
level scala das aktuelle level und damit
will ich sagen hat dieses video
geschafft mich dazu zu bringen dass ich
keine rasse davor bis nicht so wirklich
gemocht aber ich sage nichts bevor ich
noch weiter aus was das was von diesem
video leute wenn ihr keine genfern seid
habt ihr schon längst bislang gelassen
und du dummer [ __ ] du bist nur
neidisch auf sie in die kommentare
geschrieben vielen dank dafür falls
nicht gerade meine kommentare wir jetzt
die person dafür wie ihr seht wir sie
vorher gesehen habt danke und